I went with the girlfriend a girlfriend
now you're very open about sometimes
your troubles what I think well I'm just
saying that you've described some of you
know you were getting all your hips or
your the right you and the girlfriend
getting along well did you stay in a
nice hotel no here's a deal like I
booked it through yeah I got a deal you
know on the something you know credit
card points or whatever so I don't know
what I was getting into and turns out it
was a timeshare like it was a condo
you're basically when you go on vacation
you stay at a timeshare you're staying
at someone else's house you know you
walk in their crappy you know furniture
decisions or ugly utensils you know
they're bad decisions about decor and
there's always that one closet that's
locked you know any that's the weirdest
thing like if you have a lock to drawer
or closet and the condo you're staying
in it becomes like the subtext of your
vacation you're like what's in there we
got to get in there what do you think's
in there like it's the Ark of the
Covenant you're gonna open it angels are
gonna fly out and not some space you
know what do you think's in there there
garbage is in there anyways where you
stayed there at a condo did you and your
girlfriend have a romantic time there
yeah well you know you do what you can I
am
it was our first trip together we had a
nice time but you know it's hard cuz
we've never traveled together and it was
a condo and right away you know we walk
in and we're both sort of like yeah okay
what's in the cabinet but but it was why
it was right on the ocean alright so I
kind of you know let it go and it
literally it was like there was a
balcony and then there was the ocean
that was it
so right when we walk in like it's okay
and then I walk out to the balcony
because the ocean is there I'm like this
is awesome look at the ocean then I
noticed she's in the kitchen you know
playing with the sink and I'm like look
at the ocean she's like the water
pressure sucks and and then like I walk
back in I'm like what is wrong with you
we're in Hawaii this is beautiful who
cares about the water pressure look at
the ocean and within a minute or two
she's crying and and then like I love
this moment like okay we broke the place
in you know it's just now it's our home
she's crying you're in the next room
yelling at a rooster you know come
together but it was actually you know we
had a lovely time because I know she'll
watch this and she's like why do you
always characterize me like that she's
not like that it it was all mine
maybe I'm either interview
I don't know why my she's lovely and we
had a lovely time out you know but if
you do any activities did you get Liz
you get out on the water to go on you
know that's the thing you want to do in
Hawaii is get on the water yeah we did
we took I was i yes yeah I've been in
Hawaii twice I've been to Kauai twice
with both of my ex-wives so I brought
bring them together no no no but the
point is I had a lot more baggage than
what we brought yeah and I I found
myself I found myself saying this a lot
I didn't do this with them just as
you're about to go down the zipline
[Applause]
you're coming with me to my house they
show us so much trouble now you're in
trouble I'm fine look at me
you're in trouble with me pal you want
to hear about the boater we at a time
we're so out of time seriously I got
what I needed
[Applause]
tell me about the boat the commercial
yeah yeah laughs yeah this you know what
you're doing you're setting me up for
the next time I'm here where I get to
say like you know after the last
appearance I broke up with my girlfriend
I think anything to go tell us about bad
mother
right here you know yeah you're plugging
your next appearance plastic I've
already paved the way for an amazing
appearance next time this is gold and
guess what
you are welcome thank you